appeals court judge has declared war on
what he sees as partisan bias in the
news media
the judge decrying the treatment of
conservatives in american society
and calling for the supreme court to
overturn a landmark legal precedent that
protects
news outlets from lawsuits over reports
about public figures
senior political analyst rick hume has
some thoughts on that tonight good
evening britt
i wanted to start though with secretary
mayorkus you know he did as we pointed
out in peter ducey's piece
earlier a number of sunday shows talking
about the situation at the border
i want to get your thoughts about how he
did in the messaging of the
administration
well i think what he said was pretty
hard to sell to the american people who
can see
even even though we don't have you know
access that we'd like at the border
what's going on down there and he said
you know the the border is not open that
the border is closed and then he of
course had to acknowledge that yeah
there are some people who were
getting across and being you know sent
into the interior of the country
and you know he was trying to explain at
one point what that they were doing i
mean they couldn't he said we are
um i've forgotten the word of you
you're talking about their processes uh
that we
that we are putting together putting our
processes in place what does that mean
um so it was you know it was i thought
it was a pretty unconvincing performance
at least to anybody with eyes
yeah and the the media access is
obviously a big issue as well which
brings me to that
uh question about the federal judge and
you know this judge
judge lawrence silberman in the federal
appeals court and he writes this case
this um
opinion a dissent in this case about
political impact he says there can be
little question that the overwhelming
uniformity of news bias in the united
states has an enormous political impact
it should be borne in mind that the
first step taken by any potential
authoritarian
or dictatorial regime is to gain control
of communications
particularly the delivery of news it's
fair to conclude therefore
that one party control of the press and
media is a threat to a viable democracy
uh saying it's very dangerous britt
well lauren silverman may not be
silverman may not be a
a household name to most americans but
in in conservative judicial and
political circles he is very well known
he is very much a
conservative jurist as well as a
political conservative
and his the views expressed in this
opinion comport very
much with a great what with what a great
many republicans conservatives and
conservatives think about the media he
said you know the new york times and
washington post were basically
democratic party broadsheets uh he
described the networks as basic trumpets
for the democratic party a lot of people
agree with that
and the reason this was fitted into this
dissenting opinion was that it was on
whether the precedent under which
journalists
who report on public figures are almost
immune from libel suits
should be continued or whether it should
be undone he argued to be undone because
the last thing we need he argued
is uh to have even more power as much
power as we now have in the hands
of a monolithic media i mean i just
that's where you ten seconds here but um
you don't usually see this kind of
scathing opinion
dissent any kind of no well you don't
particularly when it com
it seems a little bit to come out of
nowhere in this opinion although as i
say
a great many republicans and
conservatives would agree with every
word he said about
the state of our national media today
brett as always thank you